good morning everyone I suppose I should
announce since we're apparently on the
air that the subcommittee for House Bill
609 will commence as soon as our last
remaining member arrives so stand by
thank
you
okay it's uh 10 10 and we have waited as
long as I think it's reasonable to wait
for the other member of the subcommittee
so I'm going to convene the subcommittee
meeting on House Bill
69 and as is customary I'm going to ask
everybody to stand and join us in the
pledge pled allegiance to the flag FL
the United States of America and to the
repblic for stands one nation God
indivisible and justice for
all okay thank you very much the members
of this subcommittee are to my left
representative Tom Corman and
representative cat McGee and to my right
representative Michael Harrington and
the missing member currently is
representative Tony Kaplan who may or
may not arrive at any moment
what we're here to do today is
to decide what to do about House Bill
609 as many of you will recall House
Bill 281 which was passed earlier this
session and eventually signed by the
governor
implemented much or some I should say of
the legislative language of HB
609 our legislative researcher Christy
off fesser has produced a side by side
on
hb281 which shows clearly what parts of
HB 609 are already in law in statute and
from that we can deduce what parts of HB
609 did not make it into statute now I
could go through this lengthy side by
side but I don't think that would
necessarily be productive I know all
members of the committee uh received a
copy of this side by side is that true
Christie I believe it
is say again
please I didn't get okay so I'm wrong on
that not everybody has received one
could you send a copy of the side by
side to all members of the subcommittee
would anybody like a printed copy
printed copy yeah great looks like we
need some printed copies too so thank
you I have a copy here and uh I
can go through it if anybody thinks it
it would be worthwhile it's a it's a
lengthy side by side it's
um how many pages 21 Pages 23 pages and
essentially what it what happened with
hb281 is that the provisions of HB 609
that transferred enforcement to the
Department of energy from the
SEC all that was adopted in
hb281 and some other language was
adopted that clarified for example the
role of individual departments in the
permitting
process other parts of HB 609 were not
adopted in that
Amendment so there are other citing
reforms that likely could be
made and that's part of what we're here
to discuss
today I do have a proposal that has been
submitted on another possible reform
which I want to discuss today but before
we do that I would like to open it up to
the individual members of the committee
to indicate what interest they have in
making changes to HB 609 and what
changes they would favor does anybody
have a uh would like to start
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
um my question would be I I didn't have
the benefit of being part of the
subcommittee that met on site evaluation
and I would like to revisit what we're
trying to achieve by the changes that
we're making rather than just making the
changes if we could identify the goals
the changes because I I know there is an
understanding that we don't want the
process to be overly long or overly
burdensome but if we could maybe just
Define the things we're trying to
achieve then it will help us uh assess
the suggestions that come through as to
whether they respond to
that I was counting on you to ask that
question I knew you would I appreciate
that I think the
goal for reforming the site evaluation
committee right from the beginning if
you look back at the two subcommittee
reports um or committee reports study
committee reports I should say that were
produced the goal was to make the
process less cumbersome less lengthy and
less
costly and some of what we achieved with
house house bill 281 I think moves Us in
that direction but there are other
possibilities that we could look into to
see if we could move those goals
forward then follow up follow up um and
then the thought that I had is there was
a lengthy conversation at the recent
energy Summit uh there was a panel
discussion on the site evaluation
committee process and the attorney on
that panel had said that she was going
to be controversial by saying that she
did not think that the length of the
process was
necessarily um unto you know or too long
and so
how how do we know when a process is too
long I mean it's in the eye of the
beholder isn't it I'm just not sure how
we speed it up we just say don't do an
analysis or you know well I don't think
the length of the process is the only
issue I think the complexity of the
process is also an issue and the
and by complexity of the process I mean
all the different moving parts that go
into an SEC formal process when we had
our study committees on on the SEC we
actually produced a um a flowchart that
showed all the different steps that had
to happen to get to a point where the
SEC could make a determination about the
viability of a site certificate
application and it is quite burdensome
there's a lot of steps a lot of hearings
a lot of public meetings Etc and the
question then
becomes is it overly burdensome at this
point and is are there ways to
streamline the
process now you mentioned time 365 days
is the statutory time limit yeah you
could change the statutory time limit
you could change it to 200 7 days or 180
days that would deal maybe with some of
the issues but maybe not all of the
issues
so uh that would be how I would react to
that to that question do you have
another followup or should I let
representive fairing I do and and it's
uh just another thought about what
contributes to the efficiency of moving
through the process which would be
expertise and I think that's one other
aspect that we haven't addressed yet is
whether or not
uh whether or not there is sufficient
expertise on sighting within the
department of energy Andor the Pu the Pu
has a lot less resources now a lot less
staff um and they have somebody I think
dedicated to citing but I'm not sure how
much
information um should just um I'm not
sure how much expertise resides uh
within the grouping of people who would
be responsible for SEC now so that's the
other thought representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman as I've
said before I think I'm the only one
here who's actually served on site
evaluation committees and I've served on
a bunch of them um the problem with the
time factor which I think has somewhat
been addressed by hb281 with the changes
was simply a scheduling issue uh I'm I'm
not exaggerating when I'd say we'd get
with Mike a capino who was the uh
Council for the site evaluation
committee and the members of the
committee would sit in a room for half
half an hour trying to figure out when
we could schedule the next meeting and
it was a constant barrage oh how about
uh July 28th oh no I'm on vacation uh
August 2nd no I'm in a conference uh no
I can't make that I can't make that so
we had statutory time frames and when we
were supposed to act and they were
almost always had to be waved because we
couldn't just get the the group together
uh there was also and I'll be quite
honest about this was also some people
that were on the committee that had no
idea why they were there and didn't want
to be because maybe they were from the
New Hampshire library branch or
something like that or even someone from
the state parks that they're going what
do I have to do with wind farms and that
just made it more complicated because it
was then a lot of the instead of having
Commissioners on there a lot of was
deferred to lower level people who kind
of looked at it as almost like a
punishment for being there because well
I could get relieved of any of my other
work and I've just got assign to this
stupid committee that I don't know why
I'm on it anyways so being blatantly
honest I think uh 2 a one addressed a
lot of those things um because we've cut
down the size of the committee
substantially which is going to make
scheduling a lot easier having it go to
the Department of energy is going to
give a dedicated group of people with
some resources there which we didn't
have when there was a site evaluation
committee there was just these people
from all different departments but
really no one was assigned to the
committee as a whole and I also think a
step that was made in the wrong
direction which we can fix is putting
public members on the side of valuation
committee we don't use that for anything
else if you want to get an air discharge
permit from Dees there's no board that
has public members on it if you want to
get a wastewater treatment uh permit
there's no board that has that on there
I don't I don't know of any uh permit
that's issued by the state of New
Hampshire uh with the Department of
Transportation Dees whatever that says
okay we're going to have a board here
and we're going to have public members
on it who are voting members obviously
the public has a opportunity to come in
and testify and present the Attorney
General's office present uh appoints a
public counsel who is there to represent
the council so if even if someone can't
show up individually they can certainly
um uh uh send information to the
attorney general if a group of people
from a particular town or area want to
file his intervenor status they can do
that and they be represented they'll be
able to speak in front of the commission
and present uh Witnesses and evidence as
a matter of fact there's even a
provision in the which I think is still
there that they can get money from the
applicant so if you're applying for a
wind farm for example and the people in
the area where it's proposed to be built
want to bring in a consultant on wind
noise they can actually petition the
site evaluation committee and get the
wind farm applicant to pay them $10,000
so they can hire an outside consultant
thinking that they wouldn't have any
resources so I think the public is very
well covered and adding a public member
to the board or to the commission just
bogs things down and I don't know why we
make an exception for this is the only
one that I'm aware of so I would like to
see that out the finally um we've made a
lot of changes already um there's a as
you know there's another proposed bill I
have there just a cleanup of rules which
is sort of outside of this because the
when the committee passed rules they
went way beyond their legislative
Authority back a few years ago but I'm
not sure how much we want to change this
until we actually see it in use a little
bit and then maybe come back and a year
or two and say okay under the new
Provisions we it's working better but
here's a few changes we need to make
we're trying to fix a system that we've
never used hardly so that's something to
be aware
of so did I just understand you to say
that you're not in favor of making any
further changes to the um site
evaluation committee unless someone
could bring up a compelling reason to do
it right now I'm I just looked at the
website and I don't think
I don't think they've had any major
changes since that bill went into effect
282 or 281 so I mean major hearings so
maybe someone can correct me but I don't
think it's been it's been tried on a
full-blown hearing there's been a lot of
I mean I'm looking at these declaratory
ruling uh Renewables uh CRA capacity
Bank project Clos Chariot solar project
investigation of complaints regarding
inam wind uh chanuk solar inam wind
energy closed closed closed closed close
close close close um I'm just wondering
if we I don't think we've actually
started with a here's a new major
project and we're going to have a site
evaluation commiss committee for it and
it's going to go through the process and
see how it works so you know we don't we
we can keep tweaking forever but
somewhere along the line we've got to
try what we've got out there and uh
maybe we'll have to come back and make
some additional changes maybe it works
pretty good but we won't know until we
try
it so your comments kind of open the
door for a discussion on
a proposal that I received from Tom
getts who attended every single one of
the study committee meetings on the SEC
as a former pu and SEC commissioner with
a lot of uh tenure I think he was a puc
commissioner for 20
years and but a long
time he is proposing that the site
evaluation
committee be CH the membership be
changed to the following the
commissioners of the Public Utilities
Commission all three of them the
commissioner of the Department of
envirment of Environmental Services and
the fifth member would be the
commissioner of the Department of
energy this would be a a substantial
change to the makeup of the site
evaluation committee and is an
interesting idea that I think we should
discuss alternatively He suggests that A
P public member could
be um a member instead of the
commissioner of the Department of energy
and I would like to hear from the
Department of energy if we
could to get their take
on what role the department could play
as a member of the SEC or if there might
be some conflict with other things that
the department does is uh that would
sort of preclude them from being a
member of the SEC so commissioner Elms
and Mr shulock welcome and uh look
forward to seeing what you think about
all
this thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the subcommittee uh for the
record Deputy Commissioner Chris Elms
and general counsel David shulock of the
Department of energy um you know and
thank you for the uh proposal we have
had some some brief conversations on it
but we haven't distilled the whole thing
so I I can't speak to the whole uh the
whole thing um just to start off uh
before diving into that question um as
as referenced you know the department
has not had a role in the sighting
process prior to the passage of House
Bill 281 House Bill 281 still has not
gone into effect it will be effective
October 7th um just given the you know
the effective date after the uh signing
of the bill uh and we're looking forward
to that transition so that new
complaints that come in following
October 7th will be handled by the
department of Energy's enforcement
division um that change re at least as
far as the department is concerned 281
mostly addressed the monitoring and
enforcement um side of citing uh it it
did not have major changes to the
composition of the SEC for the actual
evaluation of uh projects that came
forward um and you know obviously that's
something that this subcommittee is
looking at um and the question of
whether or not we make some reform to
the SEC or whether we move it to the Pu
obviously is one for for this committee
to decide um some issues that I just
wanted to touch on prior to doing this
and and I think Drew Beamer who's here
uh can probably speak to this a little
bit better than I can uh one of the
major issues um that they're that they
face uh is not necessarily the length of
time with which uh it takes to evaluate
these projects but the um the churn you
know the the uh changing of designes of
public members the lack of continuity
and institutional knowledge that
develops which can make it really
difficult for them to have consistency
and Clarity in the process I think
that's something that we've prioritized
and we we did talk about that in the
state energy strategy that having a
predictable process not a predictable
result but but but something where you
know if I follow this process I I can
expect you know um you know this Lev of
scrutiny in this result is important
having that be clear and consistent and
that's why we've taken the view that the
most important skill set that can be you
know had by these adjudicators uh
regardless of if it's the committee or
if it's the um pu or whatever it is that
they have that professional adjudicative
uh ability uh that's something that's
going to be important you know you're
not going to find somebody who's an
expert in all Realms of that could
possibly enter into exciting process but
having professional adjudicators with a
clear and consistent process makes it so
that the results are something that we
can you know find in the public interest
of New Hampshire so to answer your
questions about the actual proposal in
front of us um you know if if that's the
way the the direction the committee
wants to go to revamp the SEC rather
than transfer that process over to the
Pu we're definitely happy to to be a
part of it and look at it I would say
that the department Department of energy
commissioner or design might not be the
most appropriate uh representative on
that committee we do have that role of
enforcement and I think that that's
important to have that separated right
we have a certificate that comes out and
it's our job to enforce that certificate
uh the department of energy might also
want to play a role in intervening in a
project right we might want to be able
to come in Advocate on behalf of a
project because we think it will help us
meet our reliability needs or some other
public policy goal that that is within
the charge of the department and it
would remove the awkwardness of having
the commissioner or the commissioner's
designate judging the project that we
might have a a stake in wanting to do
that now obviously other folks can have
those opinions but just it might be a
more clear uh overlap between the
department than it would be a different
state agency um that's obviously up to
uh this subcommittee and the committee
to to determine but we'd be happy to
talk to you about about that further um
looking through some of the the the
proposal and David I don't know I'll let
you go after me but um there were some
changes here that I think we'd want to
talk about um I I think Drew can speak a
little bit more to the sec's needs um
and staffing needs and uh sorry somebody
from the Pu was going to be here but
they got held up um I I think it would
be important to speak with them to make
sure that they have what it takes to
implement a proposal like this
especially if we are you know removing
some of uh some of the tools like
subcommittees that are used to maybe
divide up work a little bit uh there
might be a staffing need that just needs
to be looked at or addressed one thing I
I would recommend to this committee
regardless of which direction you want
to go um you know and I I somebody had
made a reference to the Pu only having
the SEC administrator right now the Pu
doesn't have the SEC administrator so
Drew especially once uh 281 goes into
effect in a couple of days um is one
employee of that agency but he can't
work with the Pu or the department of
energy as as a member of of you know one
of those agencies uh it would be perhaps
beneficial to clarify that
Drew worked you know he could be an
employee from of the Pu who was
designated by the commissioner to serve
as SEC administrator but when there are
times where there aren't um active you
know
um uh projects coming in or or or or
whatever it might be that he is freed up
to be able to do work with the Pu and
that can help address some of the
Staffing challenges that we talked about
right he's he he has skill sets and and
future administr administrators will
have skill sets that would be helpful to
the Pu and I think it would be efficient
for the state to be able to use those
resources uh to their fullest
capabilities so that would be one thing
I would recommend regardless of the
direction we end up going I've been
talking a long time I'll let uh David
add anything if there's anything to add
I think you covered
it representative Harrington would like
to ask a question yeah I just kind of
going back to one I think one of your
main points was the idea of separating
the um people that may be taking a
position one way or the other on a
project which we want the department of
energy obviously be doing and from those
making the decision on whether he should
get a permit or not um it seems to me is
that's a logical followup to what we did
with the reorganization from the Pu to
the doe because one of the major
complaints we had in the past was that
you had pu employees who worked for the
Commissioners making recommendations to
the Commissioners on whether or not
something should be done and they sort
of thought that was somewhat of a
conflict of interest and now we've split
that off on utility matters so the doe
is making those Rec recommendations and
the Commissioners are making the
decision so of going along with that
thing I I would have to agree with you
that we wouldn't want the department we
want the department of energy to
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
uh as a um interested party in this but
they we don't want them also then try to
make a decision on it because it seems
to me is that's just going to get you in
trouble H having that so thank you and I
and I do think that we are better
positioned to fulfill that interested
party role than the adjudicative role
um if you had to choose between the
department being either an interested
party or on the the committee um I think
we'd be better uh situated to serve in
that party
role thank you Mr shulock your
perspective my perspective Remains the
Same which is that I believe that this
is a matter that should be left to
professional adjudicators
such as the three members of the Pu with
adequate U expert help and I believe uh
we've previously proposed two to three
positions including an attorney um uh
someone with land use planning uh
experience and maybe somebody with
environmental uh experience right
um that would make for the most
efficient
process what would you think of the idea
of making the fifth member
a member from the justice department
that's someone with a judicative
experience uh well the justice
department is charged with representing
the the public already now they they are
accustomed
to placing Walls Within their
organization so they might be able to
make that
work but I I would actually leave that
for the Department to to aine
on well I know it takes us down the road
that representative Harrington described
eloquently about making it difficult to
schedule meetings but we could also
potentially put in someone like the
Department of Transportation
commissioner uh instead of the
Department of energy any any comment on
that
idea uh will at risk of speaking for my
uh fellow state agencies I I I don't
want to take a position on on Dot's
applicability other than we we think
they would probably have more um
experience with the the types of
Permitting that happens uh in a sighting
process okay representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr
chairman excuse me um I was looking over
the notes I took during testimony for HB
609 uh months ago and a few things
struck me uh one was that
there was a comment that the issue with
scheduling meetings wasn't so much the
members of the public but the uh the
people from the various departments not
being available so um I think there's
something to be said for having fewer
departments on the site evaluation
committee but I'm not sure there's
something to be said for removing
members of the public from the site
evaluation committee and I understand
the point that the public would still
certainly be able to act as interveners
but there's a difference between being
an intervenor and being somebody who's
actually on the committee with a vote
and making a decision so I would
certainly advocate for at least one
public member on the site evaluation
committee I also wonder about having the
Pu involved and I understand that it has
been involved in in some states the Pu
is the site evaluation committee but I
have a couple of concerns one is that we
keep hearing how the Pu is
backlogged and you know certainly when I
look at the list of dockets I see a lot
of dockets there and many of them not to
be decided for quite a while and now
what we're talking about is giving them
even uh a a larger role a greater
percentage of the role in the site
evaluation committee
and then there's also a question that I
recall being raised during
testimony uh by um the Sierra Club and
that was that the Public Utilities
Commission is really concerned um with
with keeping costs of power down and of
course that's something that we all want
but sometimes that could be at odds with
choosing a site so there I think there's
some question as to whether the Pu
should be involved or the degree to
which the Pu should be
involved um one other thing I want to
mention is again during testimony it was
brought out that there are other
agencies that uh do have a hand in these
things sometimes so uh I believe fish
and game because of uh some some
endangered species issues
so I'm not sure I really like the idea
of not having a member of the public and
having the Pu be
uh 60% of the site evaluation
committee if I may comment and and and
thank you for that I I would push the
scheduling question related to public
members to uh Drew Beamer who's the
administrator for the SEC and he could
speak to that certainly better than than
we could um as far as a backlog is
concerned at the Pu and and uh I think
they would be better situated to address
this but I think early on and even prior
to the transition uh that was a a more
significant um hurdle uh today I don't
think uh the backlog is a is a
significant issue with what's what's uh
there uh for the Pu um to the point
about you know their mission right as
David alluded to right the Pu are
professional adjudicators and what they
are are charged with is adjudicating
those statutory uh considerations that
the legislature have have passed and put
into effect so you know they if we look
at at you know there's a structure
question and a policy question right
what is the best way to efficiently
execute the statute what what we've uh
you know argued in favor of is the puc
being that body um it really is up to
the legislature to determine what are
the criteria folks are looking at how
are they going to be you know uh
addressing these those those are
statutory requirements that that can be
looked at by the legislature while not
um trying to solve that problem by
changing the composition of the
commission or the committee in some way
so that would be just my my thought on
that I don't know if
you so Mr shulock I have a question for
you the proposal that we received from
Mr
getts also makes a significant change in
then in that rather than having the full
SEC evaluate applications for a
certificate the chairperson of the SEC
would under Section H col 7 application
for certificate the chairperson would
become the person who reviews the
application and determines its
suitability to move
forward is that a
reasonable approach or uh is that
fraught with problems I think it's a
reasonable and efficient
approach okay thank
you now I have some questions if I could
uh thank the two of you for for sitting
in I have some questions for Mr Beamer
thank you with regard
to oh I'm sorry hang on representative
Herring has Harrington has a couple of
followers you thought you get in a way
easy here huh um I wanted to follow up
on a couple of things that was stated
there that you talked about um Mr sh
about uh having a different uh position
for um to bring in expertise in in
sighting and land use and so forth and
so forth well we already have those
experts I would Envision the way this
would work is that the dees would be
like the coordinator for the state's
involvement in the permit outside of the
actual commission committee itself so if
uh if there was something involved
fishing games Dees would coordinate with
fishing game there's almost 100% sure
that there's going to be something
involved with uh uh Dees uh I mean
Department of Environmental Services so
they would they would coordinate those
and whatever permits were required and
they would work with them uh this it
could be something from the Department
of Transportation so rather than have uh
the people with these individual
expertise be assigned to the site
evaluation committee I think it would be
more workable if we use the expertise we
already have in the existing agencies
and coordinate them through the
department of energy so if there was a
concern from fishing game let's say it
was mentioned on endangered species that
they would contact Dees and then Dees
may bring them in as a witness to
Something in the tri in the here the
process or if there was something to do
with roads had to be modified or
something they get someone from doe do I
just don't think it's necessary to bring
in more people if we could coordinate
using the people we already
have I think you'd be asking an awful
lot of the puc right
um to to make sure that all of that work
has been done right and there are always
going to be gaps because Dees and your
perating agencies are only going to be
looking at permitting criteria which
don't always cover citing criteria
number of handicap parking spaces
whether it's going to have an whether
something that Dees would permit right
would have an un effect on the local
economy right that's a separate
consideration and the Pu might need some
expertise in looking at those land use
issues and land valuation
issues economic issu it may be better to
hire specifically for a particular
project then with a consultant rather
than bring on full-time staff and um so
the uh I think the last proposal had
opportunity for both okay yeah and and
one other thing i' just like to mention
um I never heard Once In Site evaluation
committee processes that I was involved
in where anybody from the p UC brought
up the fact that we shouldn't be looking
at this project because it may affect
electric rates one way or the other that
was basically considered that's a
separate issue that's electric rates are
a separate issue has really got nothing
to do with this so I I just want to make
sure that that did not become an issue
where people said well we shouldn't
build this type of plant because uh it's
going to have some effect on electric
rates it was always what are the rules
with the for the site evaluation
committee do they conform to the rules
are there any modifications we have to
make in it but never did cost of the
output product become an
issue you know uh existing
SEC legislation and
rules have attempted to set up a process
similar to the planning board process at
the local level so you enact rules and
ordinances in your town and then the
planning board makes decisions about
individual site applications based on
those rules and regulations and if a
developer complies with every Rule and
regulation then you really cannot say no
to a
development and the site evaluation
process could benefit from being run
similarly I think to that planning board
process you put into statute and to
rules those principles that you think
are
critical and then
evaluate applications based on their
success in following those critical
rules uh so I if whatever process we set
up can get us closer to that
uh that reality or that aspiration then
I think that's a way we can go
representative uh McGee had a question I
think thank you Mr chairman yeah I was
just uh looking at the recommendations
here that we have before us and under
item five it says the senior serving
attorney member of the Public Utilities
Commission s Shall Serve as the
chairperson and chief executive of the
committee and May and it goes on so um
not all the members of the Pu currently
are attorneys right so would that be
Colton Simpson or or would that be this
is the serving senior attorney of the Pu
serving attorney member turn on your mic
please there's always an attorney
there's always there has to be one at
least by law
right so so it's defining who in the Pu
would be sort of the chief adjudicator
right the chairperson attorney okay
correct it would it would have to be an
attorney basically is what it says
okay okay I have I have another question
for you guys if I could um I brought up
earlier the fact that at the New
Hampshire energy Summit this year there
was a panel on sighting and um everyone
on that panel had some experience
with uh with citing in New Hampshire and
the issue um and each of the members
were asked if there was one change you
could make what would it be and um uh
Mark sanbor said properly fund the SEC
and I think he was
um looking at the fact that without
adequate staff in some cases or perhaps
expertise associated with the group that
um like the land use expertise I think
is where
uh I would be concerned if the
adjudicative body didn't have that
experience on the board because I serve
on a zoning board and I know that the
town planner attends those meetings and
he often will insert information that no
matter how knowledgeable you are um they
have a different level of understanding
so I'm wondering if that piece might be
missing in terms of a statutorily
assigned person so that we know that
that expertise would exist but on the
funding side it sounded like what he was
saying is that without without staff
dedicated to that process when we do
have a
project we may not
uh we may not be able to move fast
because we don't have somebody who's
really a professional in that area so
could you comment on that sure and and I
think my suggestion earlier of having
the administrator of the SEC be a member
of the Pu staff is a two-way street so
he can he can give his services to the
Pu when there aren't a lot of sighting
issues it also allows him to draw on the
resources of the Pu more effectively and
efficiently when there are times where
there is a greater workload um that that
would be of benefit um but having a
well-resourced sighting uh operation is
going to be important if we're going
to make improvements anywhere we can
make whatever structural changes we have
but if we don't have the resources to
actually execute that um it it's it's
all so this may seem a little in the
weeds but I'm not sure I really
understand since we've you know re
reorganized the Pu the regulatory piece
versus the agency piece um how many
staff remain with the Pu and what
they're devoted to and then what
resources exist in the doe to support
the Pu or the SEC at the time that
there's a sighting project so I think
understanding that better would be
helpful yeah uh the the department has
about 75 uh employees it's it's been
very variable especially with Federal
funding that's come in and we've had um
a number of full-time temporary
positions that have been created uh the
commission I think is around 20
employees uh the SEC has one and the
office of the consumer Advocate has uh
six positions now uh with the passage of
a uh the state budget so um that's about
the breakdown um obviously we have a a
varied role at the department um you
know where our regulatory and attorney
staff would be the most likely to have
some participation in a future where um
we are more uh or we participate more in
the sighting
process go ahead so just to follow on
the other three items that came up which
I think are relevant here um one of the
difficulties people seem to have whether
it's with Staffing and expertise or with
funding of positions
um comes from the fact that citing
matters are not a consistent you know we
don't have a revolving door we don't
have cases rolling all the time and so
one of the suggestions was to have
standard meeting times to say like the
first three days of the month are
devoted to SEC and then of course if
there's no work then uh but at least
people who have scheduling issues would
understand to that they'd have to look
at whether or not there was anything
upcoming um wondered if you could
comment ment on that and then I'll
um well I'll just put it out there now
so you can think about it the other one
was from someone who is a CEO at um at
bow at a at a energy plant saying that
there should be a defined process for
existing plants that would be sort of a
subset of what would happen if you were
citing a new a new energy project so I I
think I don't know where that decision
comes in but again if you've got
expertise on that panel then each case
would be looked at uh in a unique way
and if it was an existing plant asking
for permitting for some new repurpose of
that plant uh that would probably be a
less arduous and lengthy process than
somebody who was trying to get a permit
for something new does an existing
statute cover that uh eventuality as I
recall
I have to stretch my memory I know it
does cover substantial additions I could
help out here Mr chairman yeah it's a
substantial change the problem of course
is that uh everybody has a different
definition of what a substantial change
is when they put the scrubber on the
meramac plant that was a huge debate on
what exactly constituted a substantial
change so there is a provision in there
to drastically minimize the amount of
going but it's that definition of
substantial change that's not defined in
um I don't know exactly how you come up
with one that that can be defined I
guess you could come up with something
that says you know the value of the
plant is x amount of money and if you're
going to spend more than 10 10% of that
then it's a substantial change or
something but right now it's not defined
and and I I think F further legislative
Clarity there would be helpful I think
from a policy perspective we would be
supportive of something that that made
that more clear um to your first
question representative um I would defer
that if you don't mind to either the the
SEC administrator or the Pu we just
don't have anything with the
scheduling representative Arrington yeah
yeah one thing I noce the the the
funding issue has come up a lot over the
years and it is obviously something that
has to be addressed but I think we need
to make a very basic decision on this
the original intent was that the funding
was going to be provided by the
applicant and that's why they have this
various fees that they have to file when
they do this so the concept was that um
the members of the side of evaluation
committee were going to take on other
duties as assigned uh to fill their role
on that committee but as far as the uh
the cost of we had it uh like I say Mike
I capino was the outside attorney his
his uh costs uh any Consultants whatever
all that was taken as a charge to the
applicant so if we want to go away from
that that's a that's a real basic
decision I think needs to be made up
front the is the con concept going to
stay with the idea if you want to build
something and it cost the state x amount
of money to approve it then you should
be paying a a good a good portion of
that money in order to get it so and
that that's something that we need to
look at and thank you representative I I
would just reiterate that's that's uh
why I think it would be a a something we
would strongly recommend to have the SEC
administrator be a part of the SEC or
the Pu staff um so that there are those
times where you know it's a chunky sort
of uh flow that that where there are not
a lot of uh projects pending the SEC
administrator can continue to work work
efficiently and if they're doing say
utility assessment funded work then they
can be funded properly and we don't we
remove that lumpiness um and smooth that
out now HB
281 did add language to statute about
funding it for example gave the
department
the ability to charge directly to the
application for any monitoring and
enforcement costs that the department
incurs and it also allows the department
to engage additional technical legal or
administrative support to fulfill the
requirements of of uh this chapter
meaning the the work it does for the
SEC that was pretty specific to the
Department itself do you think there's
other funding support that the SEC
itself needs beyond
that I'll let David jump in here in a
sec but to do my to do my part um I
think you know obviously when we're
talking about new funding or resources
we aren't talking about on behalf of the
department I think we feel we're well
well situated with the passage of 281 to
fulfill our responsibilities within the
statute we are just envisioning you know
the difficulties that the Pu or the SEC
whatever ever it ends up being might
have uh and and we could certainly think
and and look at what might needed to be
added to so that they have the resources
they need David that was kind of a word
salad I
did I he's accurate that we did make
sure that we got all of the funding that
we
needed um I would have to go back and
make sure that
the look at the the commission's needs
the puc's needs well maybe this would be
good segue to U ask you gentlemen to
step aside and bring up drew breamer the
current SEC administrator uh to maybe
clarify some of these questions for us
um based on his experience and his
knowledge of the SEC
process so Mr Breer could you refresh us
for how long you have actually been the
SEC administrator at this
point
microphone it's been about 16 months I
came on in very early July of last year
okay great so we'll come back to the
funding question but I think it's
important to address a couple of the
questions that my colleagues have raised
with regard to the operation of the
SEC one
was the question of churn
as the commissioner described it where
there is
a revolving door of persons being on the
committee off the committee on the
committee off the committee
Etc is that an issue that we could
somehow figure out how to address that
would be my first question and then the
second question is the question that
representative McGee raised
expertise
so representative Corman thinks we need
a public member on the
SEC
but I think we frequently end up with an
expertise deficit if we have a public
member on the
SEC so I'd like to hear you address both
churn and
expertise
and suggest any remedies that we might
legislatively pursue for those two
issues regarding the churn we certainly
have a lot of people cycle through on
the antrum investigative subcommittee
it's a three-person
subcommittee uh one of those is a Dees
design we've had three of them in the
year that I've been on the
SEC um a couple of them retired if I
recall correctly and um one of them was
sick and needed to be um
replaced my preference is to schedule
these things when we can get as many
people there as possible we can always
roll with a
quorum but on a panel that is comprised
of nine people I think we should get as
close to nine as we can on any hearing
so the um churn has been an issue
because when you get new people in there
all the time um you're always bringing
them up to speed on the history of the
case imagine any other adjudicative
proceeding that you might be involved in
that involved a court and then imagine
they keep cycling in a new judge or they
keep replacing members of the jury it
just hurts
continuity the issue with the
scheduling um that representative
Harrington referred to is that you know
the folks we rely on with the expertise
meaning the uh commissioners of
different
departments they will typically appoint
a design
and that design will be of varying
expertise I've been blessed so far
they've all been very good
um
but um you know scheduling them when
they have a full-time job working for
the state and then scheduling the public
members is always a little bit of an
issue and um we have had a public
meeting we've been trying to have for a
couple months now it's just a endof year
business meeting of the
SEC and it keeps getting delayed just
based on different things coming up and
different people not being able to make
it and the issues we're going to
deliberate at this as far as business
goes a lot of them have to do with the
operations of the committee what our uh
protocol will be for remote
participation things like that and we
really want everybody to be there
because we want them all to have input
and it's really difficult finding a Time
when they're all going to be there so um
regarding the aggregation of
expertise I think
optically it certainly um looks like
we're aggregating a lot of expertise on
the committee um I think the fact is
that when you look at the permitting
process sort of holistically
here if you're going to build or attempt
to build let's just say a transmission
line you're going to have to go to Dees
for some type of wetland perm probably
and you're going to have to go to dot
because you're going to cross a highway
and you're going to have to go to
cultural resources and you're probably
also going to have to go to fishing game
even though they're not on the SEC and
you're going to go to all of these
agencies where they have their own
experts review the project as part of
their own internal permitting process
that also includes public meetings by
the way so I don't really
see the lack of quote unquote experts as
AI ability I see the lack
of being able to depend on what we would
call hearing officers Andor professional
adjudicators people who know how to run
a hearing people who know how to
adjudicate complex
matters again I've been blessed
everybody I've worked with public State
pu they've all been
great um but I think when we build a
system or when we try to build a system
that's resilient for the future we don't
necessarily base it on the fact that I
am quite fond of commissioner Scott I
think he's great you know so I would
love for him to continue on the SEC but
does it make sense to keep Dees on the
SEC just because I like commissioner
Scott you know um I don't know um that's
that's for you folks to decide but I
think the cleanest way is to bring the
process in alignment with the current
people pu process um the simple first
step would be at minimum to move me over
to the Pu even if we keep the entire SEC
committee the way it is because I have
virtually no resources I have to rely
pretty heavily on external Consultants
to get things done um and I could be an
extra set of hands for the commission as
needed and they could be an extra set of
hands for me when we have a big project
come
through excellent I appreciate those
answers but before we leave the question
of churn I have to ask you your opinion
of the potential of the suggested um
change that we have been discussing here
this morning about reducing the number
of members on the SEC from its current
level of 9
to5 even if uh even if we can't right
this minute determine who those five
would
be would reducing the number to five
reduce the churn
problem absolutely it would reduce the
churn problem and mostly because the Pu
are full-time adjudicators for the state
you know um they're not when you're
relying on the do commissioner or the
dees commissioner um they they have very
serious responsibilities managing very
large complex agencies um
they do a very good job on the SEC but
oftentimes rely on designes my
preference would be to reduce it to the
members of the Pu I also agree with what
uh commissioner Elms had to say that if
there are going to be additional
members doe probably wouldn't be a great
choice because they're already going to
be involved doj probably wouldn't be a
good choice because they're already
going to be involved as well
um if you were looking for the most
gerine Department that would probably be
do and Dees because everything goes
through the environment and everything
crosses a highway or uses right of way
you know most things so if you were
going to do that model I think something
along the lines of Dees and do would
work but my preference is to just have
it go to the
Pu final question uh on this issue if we
did reduce the commission to the three
Commissioners the commissioner of Dees
and then a fifth member and if that
fifth member was a member of the
public could we would it be useful to
require that that person have be a
lawyer and have a judicative
experience it's a good question um when
we just when we talk about the members
of the public and again I've been very
blessed I just want to reiterate that um
a lot of people seem to think that this
is sort of like jury duty you know where
you're getting like a Grassroots you
know person on the committee and these
folks are really um politically
connected people who are you know close
to the governor and I've been blessed I
had Mayor Bob Baines from Manchester he
was great uh Senate President Tom Eaton
was great um you know um um Susan Dupri
is great they're all they're all great
but um they're not necessarily bringing
expertise I know that one of the
full-time public members presently has
to be an attorney um it doesn't specify
what type of attorney they just have to
be a member of the
bar um I would say this if we were going
to have a public member that would be
helpful yes that would be very helpful
now I again my preference is that we
just go to the Pu but if we're going
going to do some hybrid model of the Pu
plus Dees plus a public member then
having that member be a lawyer would be
helpful because you know keeping in mind
one of the Pu Commissioners is always an
attorney one is always a uh engineer I
believe and then in this case uh prep is
an economist so um they they kind of
round out the expertise pretty well
presently um but I see no harm in making
a requirement that that person be a
lawyer okay and as I promised we'll now
move on to the question of
funding the uh unless you had a had
question about M okay one other question
about membership I one too I think Tom
or maybe or maybe
three maybe okay go ahead okay in
listening to the description of the
makeup of the committee um I think I
understand the idea of having someone
with legal experience being helpful to
them understanding their role as in in
an adjudicative setting but we had
discussed earlier on and I believe
um uh Mr shulock also reiterated the
idea of having land used expertise
available to the body um and I think
that the that that land use perspective
could be an expertise that we require of
the public member rather than having
them just be involved with an
environmental group or something like
that if if the person actually had
background in understanding land use
they might be more helpful to the board
because they would bring an expertise
that maybe doesn't reside on the board
already so I'm wondering whether we
could get a land use attorney or require
something really specific in terms of
the additional member that you'd
want I think you know that idea is
sounds fine to me um you know the issue
with um just having the person be a
member of the bar in good standing is
does a Veterinary malpractice attorney
really bring anything you know like
unique experience or a DUI attorney you
know probably not so to the extent that
we can um require a public member or a
theoretical future public member to have
subject matter experience I think it it
wouldn't hurt yeah representative
Harrington has a
question yeah thank you um I'm just
going to go through the scenario let's
just leave the adjudicate process here
aside let's say it's the Pu or whether
it's I think obviously reducing the
numbers from 9 to 5 or 9 to three is
going to be a huge step in the right
direction towards getting rid of the
so-called churn as well as the
scheduling issues but what I'm trying to
Envision here is we we keep talking
about expertise yet we have a huge
amount of expertise in the state between
as you said just about anything that
gets built it's got to get it whether
it's a supermarket or a manufacturing
plant or a energy plant has to get
permits from Dees do and who knows who
else maybe fishing game if it's
affecting something so we have that
expertise there I would Envision and I
want to get your your thoughts on this
is that the de Dees Department of energy
would be the sort of the advocate for
the State of New Hampshire and they
would uh uh address all the appropriate
departments basic could be every
Department in the state and say Here's
what's going on someone wants to build
an energy project here's a description
of it if you want to get involved
contact us and we'll represent you uh at
any future hearings so that every
department will have as much input as
they feel they need or if it's a case of
someone that says you know this there's
no issues here with uh fishing game or
the state parks department or whatever
so we don't need to be involved but they
would be the coordinator of that and if
there was a shortage of expertise on
some particular project because it was
different or unique or brought on some
new thing that hadn't been thought of
then uh they could get a consultant to
uh come in and give expertise on that
and you know of course you would be the
coordinator of all this but then it
would be sort of we would
have the state through the department of
energy Department of energy we would
have the state through the through
Department of Justice through the
Attorney General's office representing
the general public then we'd have any
interveners which would normally be
groups of people maybe the towns it's
going to be in typically they they file
for interven status uh it could be some
outside Environmental Group or something
like such as that and these would all be
making their case in front of the uh
whoever this adjudicative body was does
that seem like a workable uh platform
for
you I am uh hesitant to um suggest how
Dees theoretically should you know be
involved outside the way they're they're
currently involved I wish there was a
Dees person here
um when you say d you're talking
Environmental Services yes sir okay yes
sir and it was I I apologize you had
said Dees would be kind of the
aggregator no Department of energy
energy energy department and they would
contact Dees because obviously anybody
that's going to build something like
this is going to get multiple permits
from Dees they're going to probably get
multiple permits from dot maybe fishing
game and maybe some other agency I
haven't even heard of but the department
of energy would be the coordinated to
make sure every con every Department was
contacted and every Department that it
import was represented so if it say if
it's a somewhat of a minor issue with
fishing game rather than have somebody
attend days and days and days of hearing
they could make their presentation
through the through the department of
energy and you know if and when someone
had to testify they could do that but
they wouldn't be a main coordinator of
it they would say okay call me up when
you need me to come and I'll be there
for the two hours that I need to testify
on why we need to protect the bnell
thrush or something like that uh but
that would be their involvement and then
you would also of course have the the
public Advocate through the Department
of Justice but uh rather than have each
department trying to come in there and
do something they would all work through
the department of energy um I'm gonna
let commissioner Elms take that maybe
after you folks are is that appropriate
sir okay thank you yeah that's fine all
right let's move on to the question of
funding uh whoops representative Corman
has a question first thank you Mr
chairman excuse me I have a couple of
questions one is with the current
composition and with the proposed
composition there are ex officio
positions and then members of the
public for
different uh different applications do
the members of the public vary or is it
that you're appointed to the SEC and you
hear everything during your
term we have uh two full members the
full members are presently James jalbert
and Susan Dupri one of those is required
to be an attorney that is uh Miss Dupri
we also have part-time members okay so
when the full SEC convenes it is only
the full-time members who participate
it's only Jim jalbert and Susan dpri as
the public members the part-time public
members who in my tenure have included
Bob Baines Tom Eaton uh Lisa
no um and um um um George casses okay
four of them they are drawn at random to
sit on subcommittees presently so when
we form a
subcommittee the commissioner the
chairperson commissioner goldner will
appoint a
subcommittee uh that will typically
include one member of the Pu although it
doesn't always have to it'll include one
of the other members of the full SEC and
then it will include one of these
part-time public members who are drawn
at random and the statute actually
specifies they have to be drawn out of a
hat okay once you've been drawn you
don't come up again until I've cycled
through everybody so theoretically it
could be a drawing of of one name you
know but the way it works is you know um
commissioner goldner says we have a we
need a subcommittee for this issue with
C Brook um I'm appointing prep I'm
appointing um you know commissioner
Scott and then I'm instructing the
administrator to draw the name of a
public member out of a hat um
commissioner Scott sends us a letter
saying I'm appointing soand so from my
department to sit in my stad Drew takes
a hat um draws a name out and the name I
draw is Tom Eaton so then Tom Eaton is
is the public member on that docket on
the subcommittee level so you have
full-time members right now and you have
part-time members the
full-timers participate on the full nine
member uh panel and the part-time
members only participate on
subcommittees so it's it's a little odd
but the uh you know it's just how we do
it theoretically to break up the work
the subcommittee structure was was
implemented with the idea that it would
create less work uh for the full
committee yeah thank you Mr chairman and
thank you that was very helpful thank
you sir uh my second question relates to
this uh notion of flexibility so right
now you are not under the Pu as I
understand it but you're suggesting
perhaps you should be within the Pu
administrative
umbrella um and and I understand the
desire for the
flexibility the question is do you
always have work in front of you
I was have sorry I always have some work
in front of me it's I'm not always super
busy um you know um recently I've been
focusing on things like this and we're
applying for some federal grants so
there's there's enough things going on
um the thing that kept me busy
predominantly
um up until the legislative change that
sent enforcement to doe was the
enforcement because the way enforcement
worked with me with the onep person
agency is I would do some of the
investigation myself I would rely
heavily on either intragovernmental
billing to bring people from other
departments in um in this case there was
a sound issue so we brought in the sound
guy from
do um and then he just sends me bills
and we also rely heavily on external
contractors we hired a Contracting firm
that does sound studies for a lot of uh
wind farms in the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts and had a good TR track
record um the issue there with
Outsourcing investigations to um
external
contractors is um you know optically I
prefer that the state the state as a
proper entity handle investigations you
know similarly to how if if you were
being investigated for something by the
state and they said we're just going to
Outsource the investigation to this Law
Firm you know to do it instead of you
know instead of the AG doing it so um
we've done um um I forget the question I
apologize want a little tangent there
well so just to to finish up would it be
fair to say that with uh enforcement
moving over to doe that does free up
some of your time and therefore you
would be more useful to the puc were you
to be transferred to pu yes that's
accurate and um you know the Pu um will
EB and flow just like the SEC will EB
and flow they have a steadier workload
than I do of course um I think their
interpretation um and by they I mean the
the commission the three Commissioners
is that I would be
useful um as kind of a flex player over
there to pick up work as assigned and
then in the instance of me having a lot
of work so the theoretical massive
transmission project big sighting of an
energy facility I would be able to
borrow one of their staff attorneys or
staff analysts to be a second set of
hands for me so it would be a lot of
give and take I think it would work um
pretty well you know because um we we're
trying to be efficient here I think in
New Hampshire we do that very well and
um you know the alternative would
probably be just growing the SEC giving
me staff and that doesn't really make
sense because then you'd have people
sitting around doing nothing whereas
instead of having more people doing
nothing we have an opportunity here to
make the people we already have do more
you know so right thank you
representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um I would like
to put the question to you where you
talked about scheduling upfront in your
testimony um the question of whether
having stand standard meeting times or
uh you know regular
SEC date and time would be helpful to
all the participants involved if you had
sort of a standing meeting that could be
canceled if you didn't have any business
before the SEC but if you went the
recommendation in the um in the panel
discussion was the first three days of
the month you know that kind of thing so
I I don't know how long is generally set
aside for hearings when they do come but
that type of an idea do you think that
would be something that would be helpful
to you it would be in the in the present
volume of work that the full SEC gets
which the the sub committees have been
meeting more regularly but in the
present volume that the full SEC gets it
would result in just a lot of cancelled
uh meetings now I've brought this idea
up um to commissioner goldner he likes
the idea too I said there's less
likelihood of having difficulty I mean I
served on the state juvenile parole
board those meetings were all
articulated a year in advance y you know
they'd give you the calendar you'd look
at it you'd say I can't be here then
then and then but I can be there the
rest of the time and then the
administrator can plan ahead and they
can say I always know we're going to
have a quorum you know um those meetings
are two weeks though so there were you
know uh probably 20 of them in a year um
realistically if we had quarterly
meetings you know that would probably
work they've met twice the full SEC will
have met twice since I've been here um
this second meeting is one that will
always happen because it's an annual
business meeting to go over rules and
fees and things like that um but yeah I
that that's a great idea and it's one
we've discussed and I think that uh we
could do it anyway to be honest with you
I could schedule quarterly meetings and
then just you know when when no if no
business came up I could always cancel
them but that that would be helpful yes
and that's something I can obviously
Implement without a without a statute
change
sure all right so funding is always a
question for the
SEC it's been discussed that it would be
useful to make you an employee of the
Pu with float respons responsibilities
between the Pu and the
SEC would that solve some of the funding
problems that the SEC
has the SEC budget proper is basically
my salary plus administrative expenses
you know I share administrative expenses
for the building for you know the the
front desk and you know copy machines
and stuff um most of the expenses that
come through me
are actually funded by the applicant um
or the company in the case of the Anum
Wind Facility most of it was actually
funded by Anam the way that that worked
was we were authorized to conduct an
investigation that was authorized by the
SEC under Diane Martin a couple years
ago and the authorization basically said
that we capped the investigation at I
think
$100,000 um we were allowed to hire
external counsel um so we did both of
those things we hired a consulting firm
and ex internal uh legal and we passed
through those bills on to um antrum
through attorney needlman as the
representative to us from antrum so they
would send the bills to me I would look
at them make sure they made sense and
then I would approve them for payment by
the facility that's what happens
similarly on uh sighting you know and as
you pointed out earlier in a perfect
world we have a flow of projects that is
uh basically self- financing you know
Northern Pass paid for Mike I capino
they probably paid for other studies
that were conducted um they paid for you
know Council that had to be brought in
for different reasons so the funding
issue
um that's a good question I think the
funding issue can is mostly mitigated by
the fact that I'm no longer doing
enforcement to be honest with you
because when I was doing enforcement but
no applications so the past you know
year and a half we had a u capacitor
bank at seab Brook that was a very minor
thing um but 90% of my time's been on
enforcement issues that is a
mismatch that was hard to navigate
because we needed to keep going back and
getting General funds to finance things
and under the current construction or
the construction that's going to come
into play later this month is
commissioner Elm said he's confident
they have the resources to handle
enforcement and I no long longer will be
handling enforcement so I believe
although I might make a liar out of
myself here I believe that the ability
for the sighting function of the SEC to
be self- financing
is probably likely probably likely the
one factor that would probably um be
needed and this is something I discuss
discussed with um commissioner goldner
is in addition to just moving me over
there as a net you know a net um wash as
far as payroll goes we would also want
to hire an additional pu attorney or an
additional pu analyst so to' be a net
gain of one person but as far as funding
I think that under the um system as
intended um hopefully we'd have the
level of applicants to finance what
we're trying to
do okay great thank you representative
Harrington has a question yeah yeah I
know one of the proposals it um it says
all applicant's certificate of energy
facility shall be filed with the
chairperson of the site evaluation
committee I'm envisioning that this
would go to whoever that chairperson was
then quickly go to you and you would go
through the Fairly lengthy process of
evaluating the application and making
sure it was complete and it hit all the
buttons it was supposed to and so forth
that's my understanding it would
probably just be cc to me in the first
place okay you know correspondence to
the chair usually also goes to me thank
you anybody else have a question for Mr
Beamer well we thank you for being here
and uh responding to our queries thank
you
okay um is there anybody else who has
listened to this conversation today who
would like to make input Mr Monahan we'd
love to hear from
you
um thank you Mr chairman I'm Jim Mahan
with the DuPont group and I here today
on behalf of a a few clients but that
would include the New England power
generators and as well as some other
clients I have that are members of the
New England power generators that have
existing uh generating facilities uh in
New Hampshire and so in a minute I'm
going to make a uh outline a specific
proposal but I did want to uh respond to
some of the issues that came up today
because in this context I've worked I
have the list but probably eight or 10
clients I've worked with that have gone
through the site evaluation process um
over the last decade or so and they
range from uh small refinancings to the
C3 propane project to Northern Pass so
I've been on it for some time so um let
me just uh some uh a couple things that
came up today they want to offer some um
feedback on um first of all um uh you
rightly identified the issue around the
need for some statutory Clarity around
the substantial addition section of
state law uh we looked at it from the
perspective of could we use that to make
a more efficient process for a
repowering of EX of an existing power
plant the problem is um is and I
actually worked with Tom gs on this and
we didn't solve it uh last year that if
you're deemed if your project is deemed
not to be uh a substantial addition you
would then exempt from the S evaluation
process but then that means you have to
go through local um uh Planning and
Zoning which I think is what folks are
trying to avoid so um uh uh that may be
a tool but the what happens if you're
deemed not substantial uh is uh is an
issue um I have not taken the get's
proposal to NEPA yet to see what they
think about it um but I will um one of
the observations I I think I think I
will hear is um uh when and my clients
are unregulated they don't typically
have business before the Public
Utilities Commission their view is that
the pu's job is to balance the interest
of rate paays in shareholders we don't
have rate payers and so there's always
the fear that if you subject yourself to
the puc for this type of thing they're
going to fall back on what they
typically do which is take a look at the
finances and the impact on rates and
costs and things like that and I know
representative Harrington today said
that um when it gets to the site
evaluation committee they take all these
financial and rate issues and they push
him aside they don't deal with them um
and I know he was not on the SEC during
the Northern Pass proceeding but that
was a huge issue Northern Pass came in
and said let us build this thing because
it's going to lower rates and the whole
role of uh uh the intervention of of um
nepco was around that issue
uh and so I think that uh it does bleed
into it and frankly I and I don't have
an answer for you about who the the the
members should be but that's a concern
that um if you to a carpenter everything
looks like a nail if you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail that's the
problem if you wait this heavily with
participation from the Public Utilities
Commission uh their view is that uh
because you're avoiding local Planning
and Zoning uh the role of the site
evaluation committee outside of the
agency permits is more of a land use
issue so again I don't have an answer
for you observation um but what I did
want to talk take the temperature of the
subcommittee on today uh is uh something
that has come up previously it was a big
part of the conversation at the um uh at
the panel for the site evaluation
committee and that is uh uh should we
think about creating a separate track uh
for site evaluation committee approval
uh for projects that are going to be
located at existing sites
I think what you heard from the part of
the panel was the among the challenges
are the site evaluation process moves
slower than the financial markets and
movees slower than supply chain uh
issues and so uh we uh presume that uh
we will see an influx of activity on the
on New Generation in Hampshire next two
three years as the uh uh Ira inflation
reduction act and all the tax benefits
of that begin to bleed uh into the
market people already penciling out
projects part of the reason some of them
AR moving forward is because we're still
awaiting guidance from the IRS and you
and US Department of Treasury uh with
the guidelines who come from that um but
I would be very surprised if what you
didn't see is in the first round of this
people trying to build additions to the
facilities or expand facilities where
there's interconnection today in um um
our view is and what I'd like to float
by the subcommittee is whether or not
House Bill 609 might be a vehicle for
taking a look at that track um I didn't
prepare language for this because it
would have been 18 pages long um if we
approached it by just amending the
existing site evaluation U process and
anywhere where there would be need
changed for it for this uh incumbent
track U make a change it's lots of
different changes and all that can be
done um but I uh uh wanted to let the
committee know if you're interested is
that we'd like to prepare a document
which outlines two things one would be
if a facility qualified for this um uh
amended uh process what would that be
and so what we'll propose is that it's
in the same footprint as existing
facility and that it's no larger than
the name plate capacity of the existing
facility Theory there is the people in
the community know what's there they
know what's going on and a lot of the
issues around uh the land use issues
were dealt with previously and so we
could take some time out of the process
uh to get us there uh and then uh what
we'd like to be able to do is come
forward with a proposal that takes into
that takes into account that a lot of
those things have already been dealt
with and develop a process that would be
six to S months long for these
facilities rather than 12 to 14 months
long at the but a big part of getting
there is congesting is condensing a lot
of the stuff that happens at the
beginning of the process um does there
need to be three public hearings on the
location you know when you're doing a
130 mile long transmission facility
probably but when it's at existing
facility uh the concept of the
applicants proceeding and the
2p U public information sessions can
probably be um crunched together then uh
the other thought was that they outside
of the formal process that there'd be a
process to encourage the applicant to
alert the um site evaluation committee
staff that a project is on the way so
they can deal with the issues about
scheduling alerting the agencies and
things like that and makes the
determination of a complete application
move along a little quicker so um that's
the first set of issues the other set of
issues that uh you'd want to look at is
the uh the four-part criteria that's
used by the site evaluation committee to
deem whether or not a project is um uh
uh should be granted certificate uh
that's RSA 162 h16 um and uh those
criteria look at one of them looks at
the financial C capacity of the facility
of of the project I think the thought
here is that if you're building at an
exist facility and you're able to
finance it you're probably in good shape
um that uh the site will not uh unduly
interfere with the AUD development of
the region with due consideration given
to the views of Municipal and Regional
planning commissions municipalities
you're part of the community already um
you're going to in engage with them um
then one where I think there may be the
need for some um uh changes is that the
site and the facility will not have an
unreasonably adverse effect on
Aesthetics historic sites air and water
quality natural environment and public
health and safety that's one I think
that we can probably float some changes
on because it's what you did in uh last
year's legislation was to say the
environmental permitting that you do
with Dees and do and all those things
that kind of drives the process and it
doesn't have to be redone uh by the the
site evaluation committee so um there I
think making reference to the fact that
the uh the application is is would be
contingent upon receiving those other
environmental uh land use permits from
the state would cover a lot of the
issues that are already there uh and
then uh the last criteria is in the
public interest we wouldn't necessarily
propose any changes to that um so um
rather as I said rather than giving you
18 Pages uh What uh if there's an
appetite from the committee I can take
the concepts of the of the um uh shorter
timeline but touching the basis around
public participation and time for expert
um consideration as well as some uh
modifications to what criteria would be
used for an existing site uh in a
document for you to review if the
committee likes it then that would be
you know turned into uh a Amendment to
the larger RSA or the drafting incur so
you could decide do we just rather than
amend the complete uh process do we set
up this different
track so um I've been the answer is yes
okay we would we would love to see that
document yes great okay and I'm happy to
share it with everyone behind me that's
they're probably all nodding their head
this is a great idea let's do it but uh
we want to be as transparent as possible
because we know you don't have a lot of
time uh and we'd like to advance the
proposal for for comment as well
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh actually just
about one of the last things you said
when you were talking about the criteria
and the uh the one about the site and
facility will not have an unreasonable
adverse effect on Aesthetics historic
sites air and water quality natural
environment and Public Health and safety
I can imagine a scenario where the
footprint doesn't change where the name
plate capacity doesn't change but the
nature of the site
changes and it could have some impact so
I would recommend still keeping that as
a Criterion and in cases where there's
really no change then it's just not a
big deal in the
application yes I agree and and to dig
into the Weeds on this I think what I'm
playing around with here is that when
the application is made uh that uh there
could be a
um uh uh um identification of where if
that criteria is being met by another
permit uh that's pending at DS or things
like that then it would be taken out of
the consideration the set evaluation
committee uh and um um that may be a way
to do it because you can see a lot of
the things that are listed there would
be a part of your land use alteration
train permit or air permit those step to
thanks representative Harrington has a
question yeah thank you yeah just to
follow up to what you just said I think
that's critically important uh in the
original application if the applicants
decides that because this is a
repowering of an existing site and the
criteria you mentioned that the
following should not be an issue and why
putting that in the initial application
and that having be the first thing that
the site evaluation committee rules on
and and if it does it gets it out of the
way
because if you don't do it that way
maybe the uh public representative from
the Attorney General's office decides
he's going to bring them up three months
later or something like that so getting
them in upfront where they you say these
are the things that do not have to be
considered because we've already got
this permit we already got that permit
whatever and get in a positive or ruling
one way or the other from the committee
on it before you go any further would be
a big way of cutting down the process
and anything you can do to come up with
a good definition of a substantial
modification or change would be helpful
I think you're familiar with what we
went through on the marac plan on that
it was just there's absolutely no
guidance there whatsoever so you can do
it and say well you're spending a
million you know $50 million but the
place is worth a billion dollars so
that's not really that substantial but
to a lot of people say anything you
spend $50 million is unsubstantial by
definition so if you guys got any ideas
on that would' be more than happy to
listen to them great and I agree with
you I think that uh part of the um the
determination of the completeness of the
application if the application
included that these other criteria are
met by other pending permits then you
know the first decision that the SEC
makes is on completeness it would elimin
it would re it would resolve those those
issues down the road if you because if
you don't do it then you'll be doing it
forever yep Y and I should say uh Comm
uh Tom get and I did come up with a
definition on the substantial addition
last year I have to go back and find it
the problem was that maybe you don't
want that because then you have to go to
the local planning board that's why I
didn't bring it forward but I'll find
that additional questions Tony Kaplan
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh Mr
manahan for taking my question uh
looking forward to seeing the document
um just out of curiosity would the
amended process that you're suggesting
would that be a different
membership of the committee or you
talking about the same
membership uh I we'll leave it would be
the same membership and so this proposal
is not going to uh involve itself in the
membership question whatever I think the
view is what that's a totally separate
thing whatever you'll work out will
comply with except for the observations
I made before about the um uh the
outsized role of the
Pu oversized
role representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Monahan um so on
the question of the language clarifying
the langu around the substantial
aspect
uh have folks considered defining like
Criterion for what what would be
substantial I mean because we're talking
about a substantial change right yeah
well what we looked at and so what we
didn't say is you know if you convert a
solar facility to a nuclear power plant
is that you know we didn't look at that
issue but it was the three things that
looked at were uh the footprint you know
are you right uh the investment yep in
the name plate capacity and then it just
became is it if it's in the same
footprint I don't remember what it was
and you know it's it's uh no greater
than 50% of the existing facility I
think was what we played around with and
then with regard to the investment piece
that's a little trickier um because some
facilities are you know more Capital
intensive but well I guess what I'm
wondering is if we're stuck on trying to
figure out a monetary you know uh
definition
is it sufficient to say the footprint
and the name plate stay the same no
that's not sub there not a substantial
change right I think so particularly if
it's a merchant you know if it's an
unregulated in investment um that
probably that's good guidance that those
are the it's really two things rather
than three
things and I did forget to mention I was
thinking maybe on back to the membership
um maybe if required a member of the
Hollis New Hampshire zoning board to be
on the the
SEC okay so I I will prepare something
by the end of the week and share it with
you and as many of the people behind me
but I'll make sure that staff or uh for
the committee gets it as well all right
before I let you go I'd like you to
answer one more question if you would
and that is we touched briefly this
morning on the the possibility the
desirability of reducing the size of the
SEC from its current nine members to
five potentially do you have an opinion
about that possible change this is my
opinion and I haven't talked to the
folks at NEPA yet um I think as a
general matter they've they've
particular with House Bill 69 last year
they avoided weighing in on that um so
um I think you know if you get the right
five or the right nine uh will work with
whatever you have um but I think a
smaller um body um particularly if it's
weighted more on land use expertise then
regulatory expertise or financial
expertise would be the way to go but I
honestly I think at this point I would
be very surprised if nepco weighs in um
on that matter there are other people
who are kind of shepherding that
component
through okay great thank you oh
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman I had one other question
question there had been some discussion
about changing the threshold for uh for
the name plate capacity that triggers
SEC uh currently it's 30 in 30 megawatts
in many cases and I I believe there had
been discussion about changing it to 50
or something like that do you have an
opinion on that I think there's a
proposal at one point to take it up to
100 um and I think that's the the 30
seems to work um
uh and what I think is important though
is that you keep the flexibility that
exists so that the decision can be made
to either bring it to the site of
valuation committee or go through local
planning zoning a lot of it depends on
where you're doing it one of the
projects I worked on was in Fitz
Williams New Hampshire 30 megawatt solar
solar project and um uh the that
Community didn't have the internal
expertise to handle with everything you
know the part-time fire chief uh and
things like that and so uh I certainly
wouldn't want to see it bigger U but in
any regard I think the flexibility for
the applicant to decide where the best
place to bring it to uh is
important okay one more question from
follow up on that the experience I've
had is this a lot of the towns they see
something that's 25 megawatts they just
don't they don't want any part of it
because they don't have the uh people to
work with it and they much prefer to
push it over to the SEC so we want to
keep that flexibility there
right all right thank you Mr Monahan so
is there anyone else who is in
attendance here this afternoon or this
morning who has listened to this
discussion and has a burning desire to
add to it if you do Miss Hatfield please
uh come forward and give us your
perspective thank you very much uh
Meredith Hatfield for The Nature
Conservancy um thanks for the
opportunity to speak to you today get as
close to the mic as you can please sure
sorry about that um firstly it would be
really helpful to get a copy of um what
folks have referred to as the gets
proposal so we could uh respond to it um
a smaller
SEC with access to the expertise that it
needs does sound like it could um be a
solution so um happy to hear the the
discussion going in that direction I'm
also happy to hear the um
acknowledgement that this is largely um
thank you largely a land use um
decision and we think it's very
important for Dees to be at the table in
a decision-making role and wanted to
point to one other topic that came up um
on the sighting panel discussion that
was at the DuPont energy Summit related
to the fact that Dees has many
adjudicative um bodies attached to Dees
that deal with things like citing of
landfills for example through the waste
Council um they hear appeals of Dees
permits so just wanted to mention that
there is really um significant expertise
at Dees around um adjudicative decision-
making with assistance from the
Department of
Justice a couple things I'll just speak
to briefly I'm not sure if they're in um
the gets proposal but wanted to
reiterate our strong desire to maintain
a very rigorous level of public
involvement
opportunities also that the council for
the public be retained it's a very
important role that that we have seen in
many cases be useful to to all of the
parties as well as the decision makers
also in our testimony on 609 um we
pointed out that we think it's very
important that the SEC is required to
deliberate in public and currently the
Pu has an exemption from that for for
good reasons but that the SEC duties and
decision- making should continue um to
require uh public
deliberations in terms of the size
change that has been discussed that
representative Corman asked about we've
heard informally
from uh small smaller renewable
developers that they actually try to
size their projects below 30 so that
they can just work with the town and not
have to go to the SEC so I think before
considering changing that threshold it
might be helpful to reach out to some
developers to hear from them
directly and then lastly in terms of
policy direction to the
Pu I just wanted to share with the
committee that um we are currently a
party in the Energy Efficiency uh
trienal program review and despite the
very clear Direction you've given to the
Pu in House Bill 549 and Senate Bill 113
the process um is kind of unraveling and
uh we've had I believe
88 U information requests from the
commission to the utilities um which is
kind of
unprecedented and uh requests for legal
briefs so that docket um is proving to
be quite challenging despite the clear
Direction um that you gave to the
commission and the parties and the
limits on the commission's review that
you've created including funding levels
and things like that so we may be back
on that but I just want to flag that
that the more clarity that you can
provide in terms of policy Direction um
the better hopefully the sighting
processes will work thank
you thank you any questions for Miss
Hatfield okay seeing none is there
anyone else who would like to uh
contribute to the discussion here this
morning representative Harrington yeah
one thing that came up in the
discussions of these various uh
committees or commissions on This was um
the concept of One-Stop shop and that's
been discussed and kicked around a lot
in other words you go to the site
evaluation committee and they would have
the basically the authority to do
whatever and the the problem is I just
don't think I think that's worked I've
had extensive discussions with
commissioner Scott on this and if for
example if there's an air permit being
issued the air permit the dees issues is
issued under the authority of the United
States government not the state of New
Hampshire the EPA has delegated that
authority to uh Dees in New Hampshire so
they have to follow the federal rules
and regulations on that and you know
site evaluation committee simply can't
come in and say well we don't think you
really need to do that in this case so
we going to overrule the the permit
because it would they'd be overruling
Federal EPA which is not going to happen
so I just want people to be aware of
that there is a provision in the
existing 609 that addresses this and
basically says if it intends to impose
certificate conditions that are
different than those imposed by state
agencies having permanent or other
regulatory Authority the commissioner
shall promptly notify the agency in
writing seek confirmation that such
conditions or rulings are in Conformity
with the law and regulations applicable
to the project in State whether the
conditions or rulings are appropriate in
light of the agency's statutory
responsibilities um and it really stop
you there that language was added to
hb281 okay so that new language is in
statute okay but it's just my my my
thing is it doesn't say what happens
there's no conclusion I've notified you
you come back and say as Dees I don't
think you can do that because of this
reason and that reason and then it
doesn't say that I must go along with
you or yes the new language at 281 says
okay says that the the agency permit
prevails okay was not clear in okay all
right so based on what I've heard this
morning in this discussion which was an
excellent discussion great
questions uh it seems to me that moving
forward on HB 609 we have three definite
possibilities one is to change the role
of the SEC
administrator to allow that position to
float with the
Pu make that position part of the Pu and
Float between the Pu and the SEC that
seems like a good change to
make number two the possibility of a
special track for reuse of existing
sites also seems like a strong
possibility for addition to an amended
HB 609 that incl modifications as well
power and then the Third change would be
to Define substantial
change in
statute um those seem like definites to
me with regard to an an HB 609 what was
the third change the definition of
substantial change
clarify does anybody do any members of
the subcommittee disagree with that
assessment are you in agreement that
those three changes might go forward
representative Kook yeah I agree those
changes make sense uh on the last one
however I'm concerned that you know do
we have the expertise to make that kind
of change the definition I think with
the resources we have available to us Mr
Monahan Mr Gs I think we can we can
probably come up with something yes
representative Harrington yeah just to
to re get to back to it's so wide open
now that it can be interpreted any way
anyone wants to there's absolutely no
guidance whatsoever uh what about did
you mention size of the committee going
there's a lot of talk about going from
nine to five and I was about to okay so
I've identified three
definites and then there's one
possibility and that is to um reduce the
size of the
SEC does there do other committee
members have an appetite to do that I
know I do
but I'd like to hear what other people
have to say about the possibility of
reducing the size of the committee in in
uh in an amendment representative McGee
yep I would I would just say I'm I'm
amendable to lowering the number I think
it's been established that when we need
input from various agencies they're
brought in anyway so we don't have to
call them out and require them to come
to the meeting so that they are part of
a quorum so that's fine with me I think
the um important changes that we wanted
to be mindful of was that uh there is
still a significant desire to have a
member of the public represented and I
brought up the idea of maybe combining a
member of the public that also has land
use expertise as a requirement and
statute so that we have somebody on the
committee that can speak to those issues
um and bring that expertise to the board
itself um so I think I think five would
be five was workable I don't know what
you are envisioning as those five being
but we can discuss that as well well the
gets proposal mentioned the three puc
Commissioners the commissioner of thees
and then a fifth person I think we as we
discussed earlier might be a member of
the public with some kind of expertise
either adjudicative expertise or land
use planning expertise or both maybe if
we could find someone representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman uh looking
at the gets proposal there is one thing
that concerns me here which is uh that a
quorum is three members of the committee
and therefore the puc could be a quorum
and I think it would be important for a
quorum to contain at least one person
not on the
puc okay let's write that
down and I think while we're on that
topic the other point that was made that
I think is of interest is that currently
the the um SEC doesn't have any
requirement for running public meetings
and I think most of our other
important meetings that involve the
public are done in public so I think
that would be another thing that we
should probably put into the statute
there's no reason for them not to be
actually the the the SEC does there is
in statute a requirement that the SEC
does have to deliberate in public the PC
does not but the SEC does so we would
not change that the existing statute we
actually um we are actually not allowed
to have any meaningful discussions about
anything without a quorum present in a
publicly announced meeting and the the
requirement is we have to announce it 24
hours in advance I always do it way
longer than that um but it has to be
public and there has to be a forum so
even when I am trying to coordinate
things via email
I can't have a big CC conversation
because if they reply to each other yes
that could theoretically constitute nonu
delation yep it's all okay thanks for
that
clarification good representative
Harrington yeah as far as the size issue
goes if we're going to improve the
efficiency of the committee I think it's
it's very imperative that we cut down
the size nine is just too many people to
get there together and then if you say
that you get into the problem with nine
so you can have a quorum of five but you
could have a quorum of five one day and
then a month later there's a quorum of
five but three of them are different
people that weren't at the other meeting
and so you have to get that size down uh
the other thing is I don't think as was
stated by commissioner Elms I don't
think the department of energy should be
on the committee because they have that
that's the thing we tried to do with the
reorganization was to get the advocacy
role and the deciding role away from
being working for the same people so
whoever was at advocating for the
Department of energy on a particular
position in front of the committee would
then be advocating to their boss so I
think they should be out um I certainly
could see uh Dees being there and I like
I say I just don't I don't understand
the the big desire to have a public
member there is we don't do that on any
other licensing board in the state that
I'm aware of or permitting facility but
uh that's not a huge issue I guess but
definitely getting the size
down that's why I think a public me
member would need to have some special
expertise to offer in order to be able
to make a valuable contribution to this
process so either
adjudicative expertise or land use
planning expertise or both if we could
if we could find it would be useful
representative Corman thank you uh one
thing I would add was during the
testimony uh a few months ago we heard a
a lot of support for a member of the
public on the SE
DC representative
Kaplan yeah I concur I think it's
important to have a member of the public
there um I also want to agree with
representative Harrington I think uh
having the department of energy as a as
a member of the of this committee might
be uh in overlap with the Pu and their
adjudicative functions I think what
we're missing uh is um a voice for the
public interest and so therefore I think
that someone from the Department of
Justice might be you know might be a
valuable addition as the member of the
five yeah we discussed that earlier
before you arrived and uh we're guarded
there already is a member of the
Department of Justice that's involved in
the process to the public Council so
having one of the Commissioners be from
the doj would actually interfere with
the uh with the process all right so
next step is or the next question is
what is our next
step it seems to me that we might want
to meet one more time with this
subcommittee to evaluate maybe a
concrete proposal so I would be willing
to to take the lead in coming up with a
concrete
proposal that
uh that includes the three definites
that we want here which is change the
role of the SEC
admin create a special special track and
I can work with Mr Monahan to do that
and then Define substantial change and
I'll work with Mr Gs and Monahan to see
if we can we can do that I'll also take
a a shot at uh redefining the roles of
uh or the members of the SEC reducing it
from from 9 to
five having
four uh state employees and one public
member and require some special
expertise from the public member I'll
take a shot at putting all that together
we we will convene once again and go
over that proposal and if it looks good
we'll vote on it and go
forward sound reasonable all right so
then the question becomes when shall we
meet so next
uh next Tuesday would be October
10th extend days okay how about if we
meet on the
17th so you won't be here for the 17th
either
okay well if we have four people here we
can
vote on a
proposal
um I suggest no later than the 17th in
case we need more time yep that's so all
right 10 o' all right Tuesday
10:17 10:00
a.m.
dislocation and I will have
either legislative language or suggested
legislative language for us to evaluate
during the course of that meeting can I
ask you for one
consideration we do have a meeting
already on the 16th I know I'm here on
the 16th and the 23rd for retain bills
I'm wondering if could piggyback them
rather
than being up here two days for I don't
know if that makes sense what time is
the meeting on the 16th uh they're all
at 10: so I believe it's a morning
meeting the meeting in the
16 you have to ask me that it's a
subcommittee meeting it is I think 159
and and I think there's a 558
subcommittee meeting in the afternoon oh
is it I think
so at one yeah oh okay all right so
never mind scratch that I don't think we
could squeeze it in that's fine what day
now the 17th yeah it's still on the 17th
10:00 yeah she was asking if we could
move it to the 16th but it turns out the
16th is already fully booked
so it'll be on the 17th at 10 a.m. and
I'm sorry you have to drive here
twice um and and will you be able to uh
send the proposed language to us in
advance so we have time to read it I
will send it as soon as I get it um I
can't promise you exactly when that will
be but obviously I have some work to do
here but thank you and thank you for
taking on that work sure no
problem all right any other uh business
to come before the
subcommittee seeing none we're adjourned
thank you all for being here thank you
out there for being here and we'll see
you on the
17th